so you're a multi-million dollar cobalt
refiner
you sell refined cobalt an essential
metal used to create batteries and
smartphones electric cars and laptops to
companies like tesla apple samsung and
microsoft your business is responsible
for feeding the world's constant need
for the latest tech without you all
these new devices ipads smart watches
and electric vehicles they wouldn't
exist they wouldn't have even been
invented
you see 15 20 25 years ago cobalt mines
were not in a good spot they were losing
money going bankrupt and closing down
all over the place
people had known about lithium-ion
batteries for years the rechargeable
batteries used in electronics today but
back then phones and desktop computers
still had to be plugged in there was no
real demand for these batteries but then
came the tech boom we were designing
this product for for the people that
loved the imac but they wanted to take
it with them everywhere
in the late 90s and early 2000s
companies like motorola apple and
microsoft started marketing all these
new rechargeable devices excuse me
sir
do you have a cellular phone
why yes i do oh
so
suddenly everyone had to have cell
phones they had to have laptops and at
the center of it all was cobalt
every new laptop and cellphone had
cobalt in its batteries without it the
battery wouldn't last that long or it
could even catch on fire
and since the 90's demand for cobalt has
skyrocketed
[Music]
in 2011 a pound of cobalt cost around 18
today that same pound of cobalt costs
around 32
and it is not slowing down anytime soon
not when electric cars are set to take
over the world and that's where you come
in the cobalt refinery
the democratic republic of congo
produces over 70 of the world's cobalt
and like other african countries filled
with corruption this has given you an
opportunity like no other
you see you could go buy cobalt directly
from legit international mining
companies in the congo that would be the
legal more ethical thing to do but it
wouldn't make you the most profit
these companies charge standard prices
for their cobalt they're not leaving you
any wiggle room for negotiation so
instead you use an alternative
a much easier way to get your hands on
dirt cheap cobalt to rake in more profit
than you could ever imagine i'm talking
about of course informal minds
mine's dug by regular congolese people
with no safety equipment no medical
insurance no sick leave with a very
diverse workforce a workforce made up of
everyone from four year old kids to 80
year old grandmas that's right i'm
talking about child labor
the cheapest easiest route to buying
call ball for the lowest prices possible
the local government calls it artisanal
mining a very nice sounding name for one
of the deadliest industries in the
country but why should you care you sit
thousands of miles away from the congo
you're not worried about kids dying in
mine shafts or working themselves to
death for you it's all about the numbers
and as long as the world is too obsessed
with the newest iphone you're gonna keep
raking in billions
my name is jake tran i make
documentaries on money power war and
crime with my team if you want to win a
thousand dollars cash all you have to do
is follow me on instagram at jaketran
and you're automatically entered watch
out for fake accounts i would never
message you asking for money or to
invest and this is blood cobalt
[Music]
imagine if you had insider knowledge
about evs way before everyone else knew
how big the ev industry would become you
could have built your own eevee empire
or invested in one before everyone else
making you billions but big trends like
this that change the world are hard to
spot so if you want to know where the
world is really headed so you can act on
the next big trend you need a trusted
source you need your own insider so to
speak that is where trends comes in
trends gives you the inside scoop on the
biggest upcoming startup ideas way
before anyone else hears about them it
sounds crazy but it's actually pretty
simple here's how it works trends team
of expert analysts pour through
thousands of market trends and business
ideas then they vet them and then they
forward the best ones right into your
inbox every single week now you'll have
the power to put the best business ideas
into action while at the same time
you'll be alongside a like-minded
community of over 16 000 members who are
all rooting for your success and you
never know one of those 16 000 people
could be your next business partner or
big investor and just like that trend
saves you months of research thousands
of dollars and all the regret of wishing
you started sooner and it's actually
working for people look at narek for
example he was a trends member when
trent's picked up on signs that the
indoor plant market was about to boom
narek took that report and launched a
d2c plant startup he announced the
project to the trench community received
some valuable advice from other members
and then he started building 40 days
later he raised 1.5 million dollars in
funding or take chris who built his
third-party logistics company sen eats
based on a trend article about the
anything as a service movement chris
went from having one customer and
getting less than 200 orders a month to
having 27 customers and hundreds of
thousands of dollars in revenue and if
you want to follow in their footsteps
all you have to do is go to the link
below and sign up and when you use my
link you'll also get a seven day trial
of trends for just one dollar so pause
the video and click the link below to
get started now thanks to trends for
sponsoring this video
june 2014 a congolese man living in a
small town starts digging a hole in his
backyard according to his neighbors he
was planning on building a new toilet
about eight feet down he discovers
something strange his shovel hits a slab
of hard rock as he struggles to get the
slab out of his way he notices something
else
this isn't just any old rock it contains
cobalt the grey stone is streaked with
bright turquoise and black if he could
get it out of the ground without anyone
else noticing he would be rich
so the man went back inside like nothing
happened but when evening came he pulled
up the tiles of his living room and
started digging from there no one could
ever have guessed what he found
their only clue were the loud clanging
noises coming from the house as soon as
the sun set
then one day annoyed by all the noise
coming from the house the landlord
arrived he and the man had an argument
and the man fled into the night in the
few months he mined for cobalt he had
made almost ten thousand dollars in a
country where most families live off
less than two dollars a day that was a
small fortune
not long after the news was out and
everyone in that same town was digging
for cobalt too they made holes in their
yards in their living rooms and even in
their kitchens it was like if you
discovered gold or oil beneath your home
and it was human nature to try to find
it no matter the risks
even though what they were doing was
illegal no one in the town cared they
weren't going to just sit there knowing
unimaginable wealth lay just 8 feet
under their kitchen tables
the democratic republic of congo or drc
happens to be home to the world's
largest supply of cobalt but the country
is also one of the poorest in the world
they don't have the expensive equipment
needed to get the cobalt out of the
ground safely and efficiently so much
like poor oil countries international
mining companies came in and struck a
deal with the government to mine the
cobalt out for them
but just like poor oil countries none of
that money really trickled down to the
congolese people in most cases even if
you manage to get a job in one of these
globally recognized mines you'll only
barely scrape by the congolese people
were left to suffer while transnational
corporations were sucking their country
drive their most valuable resource
so instead of hoping to one day be
employed by glencore or some other
mining company groups of congolese men
known as clusas create their own
these artisanal mining ventures as they
called it started way back in 1998 after
the president of the drc let corruption
destroy the country's only state-owned
vine he actually told the congolese
people to mine for cobalt themselves and
that's what they did the closest would
pretty much form cartels with the boss
workers and control of specific
territories but unlike regulated minds
that answer to international standards
the kusas didn't have to care about
pesky things like human rights
employment benefits or security all they
had to care about was exploiting their
own people instead of letting the
international conglomerates exploit
their people for them and the most
efficient profitable way to do that hire
kids of course
[Music]
cobalt might not be toxic to the rest of
the world but to the kids mining in the
drc it's deadly
every day children between the ages of 3
and 18. yes you heard that right three
years old head out to the artisanal
mines
there they have different jobs depending
on their age and skills while the adult
men are the ones digging underground the
youngest boys learn to pick pieces of
cobalt rock out of the soil on the
surface
the older children carry the sacks
each sack weighs around 40 kilograms or
nearly 90 pounds
and most of these kids carry around
240 of them a day for 12 14 or even 16
hours a day the kids drag sacks of
cobalt from the mine openings to the
waiting trucks
every time these kids breathe they're
inhaling tons of cobalt and dust if
they're lucky enough not to be killed in
a mind collapse or die of exhaustion
they will probably end up with cobalt
poisoning breathing problems organ
damage blindness deafness and heart
disease all of these issues are caused
by exposure to cobalt
and there's something these kids have to
deal with every day
doctors say the number of people getting
sick is disturbing
we have many young boys and girls coming
into us sometimes it's injuries from
when the minds collapse
sometimes it's sexually transmitted
diseases people don't wear protective
clothing so in women we see birth
defects and miscarriages from exposure
to the metal and that's not all
because of the women and girls working
in the mines they have it far worse
young girls are left daily it's hard to
give exact number but we know it happens
a lot you can tell they have been abused
by the change in their behavior poverty
at home forces them to come here some
aren't even 14 years old and already
they have children
we are here because we are suffering we
have nothing to eat the foreign mining
companies won't give us jobs they are
getting rich from our mandrels but we
stay work
on this playground from hell these
children destroy their health and risk
their lives for less than a dollar a day
but for a millionaire cobalt refiner
like yourself
that's exactly how you like it
once the cobalt is packaged into sacs
and carried to trucks it heads to the
nearest cobalt depot and here's where
things get interesting you see if you're
a global cobalt refiner that sells to
reputable companies like apple and tesla
you can't just go buying cobalt mined by
kids you'd get fined cancelled and taken
to court in the blink of an eye
your clients like apple would also get
fined cancelled etc
so to get your hands on all that cheap
cobalt you need a little
plausible deniability and here's how it
works
first you buy some cobalt from
legitimate above the board mining
companies
you have to explain where you're getting
your supply and if you mention a
globally recognized mining company
people aren't going to ask any more
questions
next you buy from our more sketchy
sources the clue sales but here's the
thing if you buy straight from these
artisanal miners it's pretty easy to
draw a line from you to the thousands of
kids being forced to work in them so you
involve middlemen for collecting cobalt
filling sacks and carrying them to the
trucks congolese kids get paid around
one dollar a day
each child moves up to 240 sacks every
day which means they earn less than half
a cent a sack each sack weighs 40
kilograms that means the kids make less
than 25 cents per ton because a thousand
by 40 would equal 25. the crusaders sell
that same ton of cobalt to chinese and
indian middlemen for between 500 and
7000 dollars a ton
and from there hobart collected from
dozens of mines around the congo get
mixed together and sold to you the
refiner depending on the purity you can
get around 150 kilos of pure refined
cobalt from every ton of mine coal rock
dust and soil
once it's been refined you get to sell
the cobalt to companies like tesla dell
apple and microsoft for the low price of
eighty thousand dollars a ton
even with the middlemen's markup you're
still raking in thousands of dollars
more than you would have bought from
official mines
and the best part there's no way anyone
can prove you knew you were buying from
mines that use kids these kids are dying
for less than a dollar a day while you
pocket billions in profit every year
but hey out of sight out of mind right
no one can prove anything and if anyone
in the drc's government even thinks of
saying something you know just how to
shut them up
[Music]
here's the thing the drc's government
doesn't just know kids are mining cobalt
it profits from it
everyone from government officials to
security agencies who control access to
mining sites make money from artisanal
mining if crusaders want to mine they
have to pay off soldiers and officials
if middlemen want to move their product
they have to bribe the cops to get
around with artisanal cobalt mining
turning into such a lucrative business
for the government why would anyone put
a stop to it and the best part as a
cobalt refiner you get to sell to
whoever you want and they'll never stop
buying from you
even if these huge companies like apple
tesla and microsoft know the cobalt they
use as being mined by kids they just
argue it's not their responsibility to
know where the metal comes from it's
yours
we ask these companies whether child
mind cobalt is being used in their
products all acknowledge problems with
the supply chain but say they require
their suppliers to follow responsible
sourcing guidelines and when people
start asking you questions well look we
get our cobalt from middlemen how are we
supposed to know where it comes from
and all the congolese kids yeah they get
to keep dying so that snobby people in
the west with electric cars can be proud
of how green they are
[Music]
another super sketchy industry is the
genetically modified foods and
pesticides industry with the top dog
being monsanto the company that owns the
world's food supply just like almost
every other business we've covered on
this channel monsanto started out all
innocent and full of potential its first
real success was actually supplying
coca-cola with saccharin an artificial
sweetener that helped keep coke's prices
down that was back in the early 1900s
but from that first win things kind of
spiraled
monsanto wasn't happy with controlling
only one part of the food production
industry oh no it wanted total
domination and to get that it had to
resort to creating some of the most
harmful chemicals known to man we're
talking agent orange pcbs and herbicides
that kill everything except monsanto's
genetically modified seeds but they
didn't stop there instead they used
these powerful herbicides to damage or
destroy the crops of any farmer who
didn't buy seeds from them and to make
sure that they had a never-ending supply
of cash flowing into their coffers they
actually made it impossible to replant
any of the seeds farmers got from their
monsanto plants it cost millions of
farmers their livelihood to try to keep
up with monsanto's prices and seed
licensing programs but here's the thing
what monsanto did wasn't really any
different from other successful
companies or people they knew they had
to step on the little guy to get what
they wanted and they were more than
happy to do it and all of these dark and
evil companies that do the same are just
as happy to get away with it as long as
the masses don't realize the truth which
is where our private documentary channel
comes in you see there's actually
already a full-length documentary that
covers every last detail of monsanto's
evil rise to global domination but
posting it in public would probably get
us cancelled so instead we created a
private members only collection of
videos with new documentaries being
released every month these are
documentaries on everything from
monsanto to mkultra the cia's mind
control experiments every gepstein and
the roots of global terror these are the
kind of videos that would instantly get
demonetized in public they're the
darkest most machiavellian takes on how
the world works and channel members have
been loving them and all you have to do
to get access to all of them right now
is hit the join button below unlike
university we're not going to charge you
55 000 to 161 000 to learn this stuff
nope just five dollars a month for some
of our longest most controversial videos
that you won't be able to see anywhere
else plus unlike other youtube
memberships there's a refund policy too
so if you join in you don't think it's
worth it email us within your first
month of joining and we will personally
refund you for your first month after
your first month there's no refund
option anymore because a few bad apples
decided to abuse this refund policy
hope you guys enjoyed the video and if
you're new here my name is jake and we
won one of the biggest channels on
youtube for documentaries on money power
and crime we make multiple videos just
like this one for free every single week
so click that subscribe button below if
you enjoyed this one you can follow me
on instagram for a chance to win a
thousand dollars but that's gonna wrap
it up stay dangerous out there and i
will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you